hello everyone and welcome to another
interesting game from round 4 of the
2018 grand KHS classic it's been a while
since we've seen some games by Carlson
and especially since we've seen some
games by maksim but sherrilyn Grove as
I've been covering the candidates for
quite a while the candidates last for
like two weeks
so definitely will be an interesting
idea that the cover a game played by
these two and like I said I didn't have
any photos yesterday so I do have some
photos today here we have a nice phone
photo from on and these are all from
around for here we have a photo of Fabi
in his yesterday's game against the
night which here a nice photo of eleven
Iranian and - here we have alia this is
the first time I've actually shown you
the the playing hall as you can see
almost all of the spectators have have
earphones so probably listening to the
official commentary I'm not sure but I
don't see any other reason why they
would all have headsets so here a game
this is from this game micros column
versus Maxim Bashir here we have another
one this is just just nice for of course
and and here another photo of Carlson
and Maxim taken from hanging from above
so those were the photos do hope you
enjoy them and now let's see this game
cousin has the white pieces and he opens
with Knight to f3 so the reti opening
and now C 5 C for transposing into the
English Knight to c6 Knight to c3 c5 now
III and Knight to f6
we have d4 and now II four and you'll
see how I will link I will put links in
the description to the interviews with
both MDL and Carlsen after the game and
we all said that he was very prepared
for this move because this was an
arrogance idea that he already employed
and white after white replies d5 Maxime
was extremely prepared for this position
with black so d Capra's on f3
d captures on c6 and now f captures on
g2 we have C capture some d6 with on d7
would check Bishop to d7 and now Bishop
captures on g2 and here g6 preparing
Bishop to g7 you don't really wanna you
don't really want to waste time with the
Bishop capture some b7 after Ruby 8 this
will only this would only help help the
black and you would have problems
developing here you can really go b3
anymore because the bishop and Knight
will pose you a lot of problems so
instead caution goes b3 Bishop to g7 and
again you don't you don't have time to
grab this especially now after rook
attacks you have to go back with the
bishop and then after Knight to g4 it's
really really not a pleasant position
for white the Queen can come to f6
attack the knight on c3 attack the pawn
on f2 it's it's not lost or anything
it's just very unpleasant by black gets
too much activity for the price of one
point
so after this Bishop to g7 cost and
played the Queen to b6 and Queen 36 is
the prepared variation and the cousin
played it in like 6 seconds I believe
it's exactly 6 seconds as it's so unsure
just 24 and here we have Queen to b6 by
maksim and here he does have a lot of
options he can go Queen to a5 maybe
pressure the knight on c3 some other
ideas are possible Bishop to g4 maybe
maybe try and exchange Queens this way
one thing you definitely don't want to
do is play something like Queen to e7 to
exchange Queens because then after
captures captures after Bishop to a3
you're not you're not gonna have a lot
of fun here protecting this pawn
you can't go b6 because the bishop would
capture your rook you can't go rook the
ch2 protected because then the should
capture some b7 attacks both Roe can see
it and a 8 and lastly if you play
something like rook a to C it's the
protected then you simply lose the b7
pawn and after you attack it and Bishop
goes back to f3 it's Europe upon is
white and but with a much better
position probably a winning position
so after this Queen to b6 move sorry
after this
queen 2d6 move by carlson maxime
immediately played the Queen to b6 and
buy immediately and I really mean
immediately without even a second
passing and the Carson wasn't really
prepared for this as there were a lot of
things black could do I call it took us
in some six minutes again to decide what
to do here in the end he did capture the
Queen on b6 a Queen to e5 was another
idea because here you have to go kink to
f8 you don't really have the option of
playing something like Queen to e6
because then Queen captures F captures
and after Bishop to b2 would we it's
considered to be a better position for
white but obviously Carlsen wasn't
prepared for this even though he did
prepare this line so Queen captures pawn
captures and now Bishop to b2 Bishop to
c6 now we have castles and now King to
e7 Knight to d5 check again it's to
cousin some against 667 minutes they
decided on this move Bishop captures
pawn captures and now rook H to g8
protecting the bishop and g7 somehow
ideas like like nice the d7 are possible
because this this Bishop is extremely
strong in this Bishop isn't really doing
anything now and here Carlson plays d6 a
very very interesting pawn sacrifice but
it will it's not really sacrificing
because the white simply gets too much
here we have King capture son d7 and now
rook to d1 check and the MBL goes came
to e7 unfortunately you can't protect
the pawn on b7 with something like King
to c7 because you get Bishop to e5 check
now you can't really go anywhere with
the King all of these squares are taken
you can only go to c8 and after King to
see it you get better page to recheck
and here you just lose a piece the king
has nowhere to go you have to block and
after captures captures now I play
Bishop captures energy for your upper
piece and winning the game so after rook
a to d1 check King to e7 and now Bishop
to e5 and here
rook of G to D 8 by Maxine and as you'll
see in the interview if you check out
the interview this will
still all in Maxim's preparation here
you could you could maybe go for for a
pawn grab would rook captures an a2 but
then after Bishop to d6 check King to e8
you get Bishop capture some b7 King 37
not allowing better up to c6 and after
rook to d3 white is doubling rocks here
on the D file it will be a very
unpleasant position for the black king
so probably I mean not probably
definitely the strongest move rokuji to
d8 and now Bishop captures on b7 rook
captures only one rook captures and b1
and now Rock to d8 rook captures and
King captors and Maxime says that all
the way to here this was all in his
preparation and he knew he basically
knew the positions that were happening
until until the exchange of rooks so
here cousin played King to f1 across and
wants to get his king into the game you
do have to have an active King in the
endgame an interesting idea was
definitely Bishop to c6 Connor to create
a wall here and not allow the Black team
to enter the game it seems like a very
powerful idea but black black can
actually fix this very easily and night
to h5 simply threatened to exchange
bishops and after a white prevents this
Bishop to d6 again white is nicely
keeping the black King from entering the
game but now Bishop to c3 next black
will play f6 and bring the Bishop to e5
and then for the exchange of this Bishop
either force or or kick it away - not a
very active square so definitely an
interesting idea Bishop to c6 but it
doesn't really give white anything so
King to f1 nice to e8 now offering a
trade of Bishop Bishop to g3 declining
and King to d7
here cousin plays a 4 and again you'll
see in the interview that cousin
probably thinks that a for wasn't really
anything to show for probably this is
just just a move that he didn't really
like it f5 by MVL f3 now king - the king
- e6 Bishop to CH check King D 5 Bishop
to b7 check King e6
see six now the two bishops are now
creating a wall here against against the
black King they are not allowing him to
enter the game but Knight to d6 now we
have Bishop to f2 Bishop to e5 h 4 as
the pawn and h2 was attacked F 4 and
here Carlsen efore does seem does seem
like a more reasonable move but he plays
the more forcing it captures on f4
Bishop captures on f4 and now a 5 this
was kind of the whole point of that a 4
move forcing B captures an a5 and now
comes the bishop captures on c5 Knight
to a5 and now Bishop to b6 Carson is
threatening to capture the a pawn and
create a past be pawn and here if you
capture and Bishop captures now you have
a past be pawn but MVL would have passed
H pawn it's very hard to say this is a
crazy position who would actually be
better here chances would be definitely
on both sides of the board so mvl
doesn't allow this after Bishop to b6 he
plays Bishop to d2 protects his a pawn
and now comes a Bishop to d8 Causton
protects his H pawn Knight d4 worship to
a for King to d6 King to g2 nice to e6
and now Bishop to b6 again Knight to c5
here Bishop captures on c5 in captures
on c5 and here with three points each
and an opposite colored bishops cousin
and MBL decided to draw the game so a
very nice preparation by Carlsen and an
even better preparation by MBL so he
really he really nullified everything
called Carson has thrown at him this
game and another interesting fact it's
been it's been like two and a half years
since Magnus Carlsen
defeated MVL so MBL didn't lose a single
game to Magnus Carlsen in two and a half
years so yeah that's it I do hope you
enjoyed it like I said do check out to
the interview with both Cara Carson and
V all the links will be in the
description below also feel free to
check out the trailer or the impressions
from round 4 also a very nice video with
some nice footage the link
we'll also be in the description below I
would like to thank Joseph bacilli
Daniel Wilson Kurt Keller Manuel Carlos
Freitas de Castro and someone who made a
contribution for a person named devil
esque so yeah and another thing feel
free feel free to use hashtag question
as the ranked HS video production team
will use your questions to ask the
players your questions in the interviews
so feel free to use that hashtag
question either for a specific player or
or just a general question that can be
asked to any player so as usual you can
check to my previous videos here thank
you for watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with another interesting video
thank you